تنتشر الاجهزه الالكترونيه في البيوت
والاماكن العامه والاكثر في مقرات العمل
خاصه مع الاعتماد عليها بشكل شبه كامل
دراسه حديثه حذرت من هذه التكنولوجيا
مشيره الى ان واحدا وثلاثين في المئه من
الموظفين يفرطون في استخدامها ما قد يؤدي
الى حاله عزله بسبب الضغط الذهني فلا يوم
عمل يمر دون ارسال بريد واستقبال اخر
رقميات قلبت الحياه اذا ما قلنا سهلتها
ولكن هل تنقلب الى نقمه الاطباء حذروا من
حمى التكنولوجيا فالاجهاد الرقمي برايهم
بات خطرا اخذا في التمدد لاسيما عقب جائحه
كورونا التي اجبرت الكثيرين على المكوث
طويلا خلف الشاشات حتى الاعتماد عليها في
شتى المجالات اي انها مشقه رقميه كما اطلق
عليها
مرتبطه بامراض القلب والاوعيه الدمويه
فضلا عن التمثيل الغذائي والتاثيرات
المناعيه الى جانب الضغط النفسي الذي يقلل
من الاداء المهني
[موسيقى]